this is the St Sophia Russian Orthodox
Cathedral less than a mile across town
is Joseph Stalin Park the winters are
freezing cold the economy dominated by
oil strangely this is not
Russia this is China's Northwestern
province of halong Jang located just 50
Mi above North
Korea not so long ago go this was the
Beating Heart of the Chinese economy it
supplied the hard physical resources
coal oil and gas the country needed to
industrialize and thanks to its
importance the region basked in the warm
Golden Glow of the party's
favor this statue commemorates one of
Mao's model Socialist Workers nicknamed
Ironman for his tireless work on a
nearby oil
field then one day China moved
on sometime around 10 years ago the
country changed Focus dirty dangerous
and environmentally destructive
industries were out meanwhile Technology
Innovation and high-skilled labor were
in this was no polite suggestion nor was
this transition slow and
methodical this sweeping economic
restructuring was executed with all the
force and velocity of an unchecked
authoritarian
regime the message was unambiguous and
unforgiving robots are the future adapt
or be left behind foxcon famous for
assembling the iPhone began building
what it ominously called a 1 million
robot army taxes were cut by 40% for
tech companies and one Province
announced it would spend $70 billion to
replace workers with
robots these were not empty threats in
2022 nearly six times more industrial
robots were installed in China than any
other
country and by nearly every metric this
transformation has been
successful between 2010 and 2020 its
economy doubled in size and its
population grew by 76 million people
China is bigger stronger and richer
today than it was a decade ago but
what's often overlooked amidst this rise
of China National Renaissance narrative
is who was
overlooked not everyone was invited AB
board this high-speed train to modernity
by very explicitly selecting new winners
the party dismissed others as
losers just as globalization favored
coastal cities like New York Los Angeles
and San Francisco China's new e economic
order favored Rich urban areas like
Shanghai Hong Joo and
Shenzhen today's model Socialist Workers
are Tesla driving high-rise living data
scientists and
Engineers Left Behind are China's West
Virginia Detroits and Pittsburghs
collectively home to 100 million people
these depressed cities remain Frozen in
Time relics of an earlier ERA with their
deet oil fields and Soviet era
cathedrals in that same decade between
2010 and 20 While most of the country
was bursting at the seams with growth
halong Jang actually
shrank in 2021 just three and a half
children were born there for every 1,000
residents less than half the national
average and if America's Rust Belt was
forgotten China's was flat out
rejected while American an are at least
legally free to pick up and move to New
Opportunities Chinese workers have no
such luxury because public services in
China are restricted to your place of
birth these migrants can't access health
care pensions or education in their new
cities even their children are banned
from attending local
schools in other words those unlucky
enough to be born in China's Rust Belt
today are permanent second class
citizens in their own
country so here's a puzzle why aren't
they
angry why after being replaced by robots
do these same workers maintain such
positive views about
automation out of 54 countries China
ranks second highest in agreement that
more emphasis on technology is a good
thing and fourth highest for Science and
Technology bring more opportunities for
the Next
Generation China is twice as optimistic
about the future as any other country
and six times as optimistic as the
US
why sponsored by nebula the exclusive
home to China actually my seven-part
original
series A lot has changed in China over
the last 100 years but one thing has not
its objective to catch up and surpass
the United
States it's hard to say where this
competitive mind set
originates but we do know that Chinese
leaders are big Believers in Grand
historical narratives xiin ping loves to
repeat cliches like the East is rising
and the West is
declining in the party's version of
History Western imperialist Powers once
exploited their advanced technology
firearms and Naval instruments for
example to humiliate the Chinese Empire
the British stole Hong Kong the
Portuguese maau and the French among
others
Shanghai these traumatic chapters it
seems LED Chinese leaders to view
history as a one-way Zero Sum linear
race a race it's currently losing to
overtake the US therefore it needs to
somehow accelerate to employ some kind
of force
multiplier China calls this overtaking
on a Bend while a more cautious driver
like Washington might slow down as it
approaches a sharp curve in the road
Beijing on the other hand must
fearlessly
accelerate until recently this meant
overlooking the consequences of rapid
industrialization if America enforced
labor laws China saw its asymmetrical
Advantage as ignoring them a culture of
build fast and break things at a
national scale it also meant quickly and
indiscriminately adopting Western
technology especially after mau's death
in the
1970s the party at the time faced a
serious problem on one hand everyone
could see that Mao's Great Leap Forward
had been an unmitigated disaster
accomplishing little and killing
millions in the process on the other it
certainly couldn't condemn its own
founder and hero the literal face of the
party ultimately the way it lyed itself
out of this embarrassing dilemma went
like this while m goals were Noble his
methods may have been flawed with a few
tweaks here and there China would be
back on track the Communist party was
still relevant because only it had the
scientific and technocratic expertise to
make those
adjustments its performance would now be
based more on its material than its
ideological
success and this success would largely
be measured by the number of smartphones
in people's hands robot bots on Factory
floors and miles of High-Speed Rail in
the process technology took on an almost
super natural Aura it became the Magic
Bullet to all of China's problems it's
state religion if you will naturally
this led to lightning fast adoption the
country went straight from cash to
mobile payments from fax machines to
iPhones in its quest to catch up it
skipped write over checks credit cards
pagers and
blackberries but this infatuation with
technology also made it vulnerable to
digital snake oil waste fraud and false
promises to see why watch how all this
plays out on the ground as these Grand
aspirations trickle down through the
party's 40 million person
bureaucracy first xijin ping wakes up
one day and declares robots are the the
future but although his authority is
unlimited his ability to execute this
vision is limited he himself can't make
or buy or regulate these robots the
central government therefore delegates
the how to its what down to local
governments to incentivize their
cooperation Beijing promotes or demotes
these officials based on quantifiable
metrics say how many robots they install
and eager to get that corner office boy
will they install some
robots as a rule when China's goals are
easily measured file more patents
graduate more Engineers or produce
cheaper solar panels you can pretty
confidently bet on its success indeed as
you can see digital technology has grown
from 14% of its economy in 2005 to a
remarkable 39% in
2020 then that's what China is good at
these incentives allow it to go from
napkin sketch to completed skyscraper in
no time
flat but when its goals are intangible
or more subjective like winning hearts
and Minds around the globe it tends to
struggle it's easy to build more robots
it's a lot harder to make sure they're
put to good
use now make no mistake much of this 39%
of China's economy is
productive as the government dumped
billions of dollars worth of subsidies
on the tech sector some of it landed on
your Hua alwayss your Tik toks your
xiaomi but for every Tik Tok there are
10 million terminally unprofitable
metaverse startups for every Huawei
there are 10 billion nebulous Smart City
initiatives you name a gimmick scam or
buzzword and the Chinese government has
almost certainly ly invested an alarming
number of zeros in it last July for
instance the city of Shanghai announced
it would spend over $1 billion on the
metaverse a few years earlier this
futuristic bus went viral for solving
the problem of gridlock by Gliding Over
traffic unfortunately it was later
exposed as a pyramid scheme but not
before five Chinese cities signed
contracts with the
company now no country is immune to
misplaced optimism remember solar
roadways in fact who pioneered The
metaverse Craze but Facebook an American
company but if Silicon Valley wins the
award for inventing the most cuttingedge
snake oil China wins the award for
buying the most Time After Time After
Time China eagerly Imports these
wasteful speculative Innovations and
then proceeds to dig the deepest
possible Money Pit part of the problem
is that private companies take advantage
of the government's faith in
technology why would they question the
usefulness of all these gadgets when
they're being handed billions of dollars
worth of
subsidies assessing the utility of
Cutting Edge inventions is hard enough
doubly so for a 70-year-old with no
technical background and triple so when
you've constructed an intricate
bureaucracy of 40 million yes men with
no incentive to give negative
feedback as a result it takes a long
time for reality to catch up with the
country's
leaders and therefore when it finally
does it often provokes a Swift and
brutal
overcorrection recall that it began
shifting Focus from heavy industry to
Tech sometime around
2010 for the next decade China Silicon
Valley enjoyed its moment in the
spotlight it's like coal oil and gas
before s basked in the party's favor
companies like BYU 10cent and Alibaba
exploited this boundless enthusiasm and
cheap Capital to grow bigger and bigger
they started making riskier bets they
entered wildly unrelated markets and
their CEOs became dangerously
popular then after 10 years the fund
came screeching to a halt as the party
realized the monster it had created and
in 2020 it sprung into action breaking
up the largest companies and regulating
them like never
before to be clear the party hasn't lost
its faith in
technology this Crackdown was about
steering the industry toward what it
calls highquality or productive growth
think less internet gambling and
fortnite and lone sharks and more
semiconductors EVs and
robots in fact China really has no
choice but but to double down on
technology in 2021 its population began
to shrink and this decline is especially
pronounced among the working age those
roughly 18 to
65 meanwhile Chinese labor once among
the cheapest in the world is now four
times as expensive as neighboring
countries like Thailand and the
Philippines unsurprisingly many
companies have responded by shifting
their production to those cheaper places
es each year fewer and fewer Chinese
workers are employed in
manufacturing all these Factory workers
have to find new jobs somewhere and Tech
is one of the few areas of
growth as you can see the decline in
manufacturing has coincided with a rapid
rise in labor intensive service jobs
these are your Uber drivers your live
streamers and your door Dash delivery
people so that's why the government must
continue embracing
technology but this still leaves one
important question why do
workers after all the jump from
assembling iPhones to delivering meals
isn't all that great of a promotion
these are still low paid and
surprisingly dangerous jobs because
delayed orders are heavily penalized for
example Chinese delivery people are
prone to extremely reckless driving
serious inj injuries and even deaths are
shockingly common never mind that these
aren't strictly speaking jobs they're
independent contractor Arrangements that
can and do disappear at a moment's
notice China's largest platforms can
change their contracts with drivers
without their
consent now that's the most vulnerable
end of the spectrum but even the
luckiest most privileged workers
programmers and Engineers are overwork
worked and
underpaid some work what's widely known
in China as a 996 schedule meaning 9:00
a.m. to 900 p.m. 6 days a week in other
words workers are either excluded from
the labor market like we saw in halong
Jung or abused as in the case of urban
Highly Educated
programmers neither are paid as well as
their counterparts across the globe when
even the winners are treated so poorly
one wonders why workers don't
complain the obvious answer of course is
that they do yet their voices are
sensored another explanation is that the
public only hears good stories about
technology thanks to the party's control
of the
media both these things are true there's
no doubt censorship and propaganda play
a massive role but theories alone are no
substitute for real world on the ground
re research at some point it helps to
just ask and that's exactly what yaahl
did for her book The Gilded
cage what she found in interview after
interview is that Chinese programmers
are aware of their unusually stressful
working conditions but they situate
their personal hardships within a larger
context the nation's
development one engineer said quote if
Chinese people worked from 9 to 5 like
people in developed countries we
wouldn't have so many
accomplishments and another China
remains a developing country I don't
think the government can do anything if
we want to catch up with developed
countries put differently their low
monetary wages are offset by a kind of
psychological wage
Pride this is why xianping loves to
repeat platitudes like the East is
rising and the West is declining these
narratives by the party incredible
leeway All Is Forgiven in the name of
progress Chinese Tech workers aren't
exploited they're part of something
bigger than
themselves many of the darkest chapters
in Chinese history have been justified
by this vague notion of national
progress from the Great Leap Forward to
the one child policy even today it's
widely assumed that the latter was
effective necessary and helpful three
myths that I challenge in the latest
episode of my series China actually in
it we also explore questions like how
was the policy inforced who was and
wasn't affected and how does China's
birth rate compare to nearby countries
like Taiwan the one child policy was
among Humanity's most ambitious attempts
at Social Engineering and yet so little
is known about it today you can watch
the entire series which also covers
myths like that China lifted 800 million
people out of poverty or that it's
secretly building thousands of
underground nuclear bombs on nebula
nebula is the streaming platform built
by and for creators it's also home to
other great Originals like real life L's
modern conflicts which explains many of
the 21st Century's most important Wars
and Windover Productions fascinating
series the logistics of X now normally
nebula cost $5 a month
but you can get it for just half that by
signing up for a year with a link on
screen or in the description now that's
just
$2.50 a month for loads of exclusive
content you'll
love